okay we are back all right this is our
21st season here on HBO we are starting
tonight
okay and uh you know a lot of stuff we
were off for a couple of months a lot of
stuff happens I'm going to catch up the
big story I think uh humans are obsolete
now
no really have you been on chat GPT this
just happened this is not even me I I'm
not even here this is just
okay the other good thing that I want
that's not a good thing
the tech area I thought that was good is
uh crypto fell off the cliff I
thought that was fantastic you heard
about that with
Franklin freed and FTX and today another
one fell Genesis another big crypto
exchange went bankrupt Genesis I love
that naming it after the Bible that's
that's cheeky
imagine naming a crypto company after a
book that says if you believe in some
invisible you'll have fabulous
rewards I mean it's just crazy
sorry bro
and this is kind of big news a Japanese
fisherman to yesterday I think took a
picture we'd never have seen this before
I don't think maybe once or twice the
rarest creatures a giant squid it has no
backbone and lives at depths lower than
any human can go like Kevin McCarthy
oh I Kid the new Republican Congress
hey we've got a new Republican oh see
there is some fans I don't know it took
them 15 ballots this was unprecedented I
think the last time it happened was 1823
or something
15 ballots to elect Kevin look you know
what Oscar nominations come out Tuesday
I know
Washington loves to look down their nose
on the Hollywood and you know I would
agree that award shows are pointless
virtue signaling
but we don't need 15 ballots to get it
done